let's have a mac and cheese competition
okay let's do it
all right everyone welcome to Next Level
kitchen where we're taking your cooking
skills to the next level with simple
tricks and even better recipes heck yes
and today we're going to get a little
cheesy with some delicious mac and
cheese recipes cheesy because I'm here
uh well that's right an American
institution mac and cheese and one of my
favorite dishes to cook at home but
before we get cooking let's talk about
the perfect cheese what do you like
cheese wise I think that each cheese has
a different application for the style of
macaroni and cheese right in my family
my Aunt Linda she was really famous for
her mac and cheese bless her heart and
rest her soul and so that's really where
I learned my Mac and Cheese Style from
was making a sauce and actually at my
family barbecues me and my cousins have
like a mac and cheese bake off seriously
seriously and some use Bechamel some use
some add eggs some use breadcrumbs all
right so it was a competition
sure I think it was like our individual
personalities on display and we left it
to the audience too uh see which one was
their favorite but yeah sure you could
call it a competition let's reenact it
let's let's reenact it let's let's have
a mac and cheese competition let's do it
okay all right so let's get into it okay
cool wow I'm up against it right now
because you're talking about Bechamel
and some really amazing serious Chef
things I am going to take it the
different way I'm gonna use box mac and
cheese it's in a box for a reason it's
easy to make it's in a box uh but now
that it's a competition I'm a little
worried but I'm gonna try and take my
Mac and Cheese Next Level Naisha uh I'm
going to start by cooking the macaroni
in the dairy love that uh but the key if
you are going to do this at home and
I've seen this on social media just make
sure that the milk doesn't stick to the
bottom of the pan I have these amazing
hex Clan pans right here it's not gonna
stick but you could burn the milk so I'm
gonna just dump my uh noodles in here
and just cook them what are you gonna do
yeah so um with this style of cooking
the macaroni cheese so are you starting
with cold milk hot milk like how does
this I'm warming it up yeah so I'm gonna
I am gonna wait till it gets nice and
warm and then I'm just gonna put in my
my pasta love that
um so yeah I'm gonna make a standard
sort of um home style mac and cheese uh
I'm melting one stick of butter so I'm
gonna start with that and I'm starting
my sauce base the conduit for the milk
and the cheese marriage is what we call
a roux right so a roux is essentially
equal parts flour and butter
um you know you can get fancy and sifter
flour if it's been sitting around for a
while which I've done so I add just a
little bit of flour
um about equal parts it's again it's
really just the conduit for that
marriage of the milk and the cheese this
is my Roux Naisha love it I don't know
what's in here but you know what's in
here magic and science and flavor this
is my Roux isn't it amazing though these
flavor packs absolutely and it gets so
nice and creamy what is in this thing I
hope cheese I hope cheese I'm sure
there's some sort of cheese Source
um and it's cool right you can sort of
get those same Vibes but maybe you're
cooking for one or two right and you
don't want to bust out like Seven Pans
right like that's true yeah I love that
okay I grew up on box macaroni and
cheese okay but you're but you're making
a roux right now because this is how you
win the competition you make a roux
perhaps well I think it's about
celebrating you know the individual sort
of characteristics of a dish I mean yes
I'm making it today did I make over when
I was seven no I ate it out of a box
all right so you're making that Roux I
have my pasta cooking in the milk making
sure that I'm not burning that and then
you know once it starts cooking it's
pretty easy for me at this point what
I'm gonna do is now add what's in my
flavor pack
and it just smells delicious it's cheesy
yeah please get in there right I mean
yeah it smells like childhood doesn't it
uh it smells like success Naisha I mean
I think this is the key to victory over
here yeah that's good but what's amazing
about these again is like it's just
going to turn into a creamy sauce so I'm
gonna add all of my flavor pack that's
got cheese in it that's got salt in it
and it's also got a lot of that texture
that's gonna make this nice and Ooey and
gooey so the question is I talked about
this before you talked about Auntie
Linda who makes the baked mac and cheese
yes right she made a baked version to me
there's two Styles baked and sort of
like it's got some texture to it or just
Ooey and gooey and creamy which one do
you prefer
uh I'm a big like I love I like the
little like crust baked one but I want
it to be ooey gooey I don't want that
one that's like separated you know okay
where the where the actual cheese fat
and the oil is coming down you know
exactly what I'm talking about yes and
so I I love it to have a cheese pull but
I also want a little bit of that like
Crunch and texture on top from like that
brulee of the cheese so you know you
asked me earlier what type of cheeses I
use
um and to achieve that I'm a big big fan
of using a few different types of
cheeses right a low moisture mozzarella
is going to give us a really great
cheese pull I also love the depth of
flavor and the salinity that come from
aged cheeses so I'm using um this is my
little fancy take on a mac and cheese
but I'm using I'm using some compte and
I'm using a little bit of white cheddar
and I'm also using some gruyere so it's
a cheese blend all right you're using
like these amazing sort of uh European
cheeses right yes I am going to take it
to the best of the American cheeses
maybe I mean they're not American cheese
but I have some cheddar some pepper jack
and then for my cheese pull I'm gonna
add some mozzarella which is really
going to give it some of that
stretchiness I hope totally uh so here's
the key now my my my elbow macaroni
which by the way I do have a rule make a
mac and cheese it's got to be elbow
macaroni I could not agree with you okay
it's like it's that that's sacred right
there okay uh so my pasta's cooked I
have now all of these sort of starch
that's also in uh that water that we
cooked it in we have the cheese pack in
there but now like you can serve this at
home and my kids would think I'm the
best chef in the world by the way when I
do this they're like my dad's amazing of
course they do but it's just a box right
it's just the box but it's box of
memories it is a box of memories but now
I'm gonna take it to the next level so
one of the things I love doing at home
is you have this like okay everyone
makes this but then how do you take it
to the next place so I'm gonna add now
the jack cheese I'm gonna add the
cheddar I'm gonna just really add more
cheese to this and I'm gonna add a
little bit of mozzarella as well so you
got the roux going on yeah so I started
my Roux I've also dropped my elbow
macaroni and I've also salted my water
right again I think every uh stage of
the recipe is an opportunity for flavor
and our seasoning so I just have some
boiling water some salt uh and I have my
Roux going and to that Roux I will add
some milk
and also whenever using milk
you want to use nutmeg nutmeg really
brings out the flavor in cream-based
sauces okay I feel like I have to take
step it up a notch I have some bacon
left over from breakfast and I'm just
gonna add that to my Mac and Cheese wow
because uh you got a rugo and you got
these fancy cheeses and I just gotta
like bacon makes things better do you
believe that bacon makes everything
better are you kidding me bacon Bacon's
like one of my favorite foods it's like
it makes everything better so we're
gonna add some meat flavor to that I
also happen to have a steak I think I'm
gonna make this a whole dinner who's
just says I happen to have a steak no I
mean I have a steakhouse right so like
listen this one was maybe a little
overcooked last night I brought it home
that's how it works yeah I'm a chef
sustainable all right so I'm gonna put
some mozzarella in here as well you got
your cheese you're still making the roux
over there right uh yeah so I have added
my milk and Roux complete so now we're
heading on to the sauce stage of this so
fancy French kitchens might call this a
morenay or a bechamel with cheese right
that's what makes a Mornay sauce pasta
just about done for me I want a really
nice Al Dente noodle so a little bit of
toothsomeness to it so that when I add
that cheese and get that sauce folded in
it's really going to continue to cook so
I want to pull out the pasta just before
it's complete and then just really to
bring this all together I'm going to
chop up a little fine herbs some parsley
some thyme and a little bit of Rosemary
here comes that mozzarella now in here
and you can start seeing
I'm getting some of that stringiness
coming from the mozzarella let me get
all of that in there oh you do that
the only thing no pressure Naisha but
the only
and you got to make a roux yes I'm gonna
drain my pasta off I got bacon in my mac
and cheese and now I need texture so you
have um you said you like the baked
version of uh macaroni and cheese
sometimes people can put bread crumbs on
them a little bit of butter bread crumbs
sort of like bake the top broil the top
I love that but again because we're
keeping this sort of uh you know we're
keeping this like Hey we're using all
these ingredients that you might find on
that platform maybe if you're in the
basement I'm going with uh potato chips
right here wow potato chips and you know
what I want to crush them up but I don't
have time and just sometimes you just
gotta get in there and you just gotta
Smash Potato Chip that's gonna be the
top of my mac and cheese and I'm gonna
I'm gonna start plating I'm gonna start
plating I have my Mac and Cheese over
here now it's super stretchy now you can
see that cheese pull happening can mac
and cheese be too cheesy can it I mean
technically I guess but I don't I would
say some would say most likely not
get in look at all that nice and ooey
gooey stretchy and chewy I'm gonna go
right over to the Bowl
and this is going to be a whole meal
because I have that steak over here I
got bacon in here look at that cheese
pull happening that's what you're
looking for right there
a little bit of cheese pool guaranteed
to get an extra couple hundred likes on
social media if you have some sort of
cheese pool happening 100
um I have my crushed potato chips
I'm gonna put these on top do I want a
little bit more cheese on here I think I
do I think this has got to be something
that's got to be really really Next
Level because you're going real awesome
like fine dining over there potato chips
on the top
we got all this texture now the salt
from the potatoes what are you what are
you going what do you got going on yeah
so I'm just gonna butter a cast iron pan
here and I'm going to add my Roux to the
pasta and really love to sort of mix the
cheese into stages as the starch
releases into the Bechamel or the Mornay
sauce because you want different things
from each cheese correct and they all
have different melt points right so
really that's the key here
and the pasta is actually going to
absorb some of that liquid so you almost
want it to be a little bit more runny
than you would think
okay I love it I love it ooey gooey
stretchy and chewy uh I now want to get
that sort of texture on top of my
macaroni so
um it wouldn't be I wouldn't be Richard
Blaze if I didn't show up with some sort
of torch yes some sort of torch and you
can pop this in the oven if you want but
what I'm going to do is just get a
little bit of this nice charred sort of
brulee flavor on these potato chips in
this butter
let's get a little bit of that texture
going on again if you wanted to do this
with breadcrumbs you can
okay there we go now my I got audio on
mine do you ever do you judge it just by
Audio I got some snap and some crackle
over here always a little ASMR never
hurt anyone okay and now of course this
is like now a meal for a family of four
over here I have a little bit of steak
perfectly cooked mid-rare lovely all
right here we go we got our steak I'm
gonna lay this out on top I need a
little bit of color maybe again feeding
the whole family here you're you're
coming off the fire you're using
breadcrumbs I am using bread crust which
are nice and golden brown and what I'm
gonna do is just finish it with some
cheese on top more cheese more cheese
more cheese and again I added in three
layers in the beginning middle and just
to finish
so that we ensure maximum gooeyness
maximum gooeyness I'm chopping some
chives are you plating
yeah so this is essentially finished oh
there it is I've actually pre-toasted my
bread crumbs so that's already toasted
through okay here we go I'm gonna finish
this off a little bit of chives to give
this some color my Mac and Cheese it's
Ooey it's gooey it's stretchy it's chewy
every good Chef's gonna finish with a
little bit of salt that platform
you're bubbling you're bubbling away
over there I think you got it there's a
little flare at the ends gotta bring
them side by side here yours is like
bubbling and everything which is
absolutely amazing there it is
Naisha Arrington throwing down the
classic I got box mac and cheese and
potato chip
who do you think won comment below vote
below is it Naisha or myself
[Music]
foreign